[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y en 5
minutos con hablaremos con andrés
hernández director ejecutivo de
transparencia por colombia sobre la
alerta que ha emitido este organismo por
la concentración del poder en el
ejecutivo del país gracias señor
hernández por acompañarnos y le pregunto
alertan ustedes del aumento de poder del
presidente de la republica cuáles son
los argumentos que da la organización
buenos días nosotros hemos hecho un
análisis a lo largo de todo este año
alrededor de cómo se ha comportado el
ejecutivo y es congruente con elementos
que vemos en distintos países alrededor
de haber aumentado un poder para poder
atender de manera efectiva la pandemia
lo cual requiere mayor agilidad en el
uso de los recursos públicos y la
discrecionalidad e incluso permitir
normativa y regulación para atender esta
situación sin embargo vemos que hay
otros elementos que hacen que este este
poder se concentre aún más y alrededor
de esto vemos una creciente cercanía del
ejecutivo frente a las mayorías al
congreso una pérdida de capacidad de los
gobiernos descentralizados frente al
gobierno central actuaciones por parte
del gobierno nacional que son
cuestionadas en materia de libertad de
expresión de participación y acceso a la
información y por último una designación
de cabezas de órganos de control que
luego de los procesos de nominación
terminan siendo personas muy cercanas el
presidente de la red
durante la gestión para atender la
pandemia el presidente iván duque ha
declarado el estado de excepción de
emergencia económica que poderes
extraordinarios le da esta excepción
esa excepción en el marco de nuestra
constitución lo que le permite al
ejecutivo es por un lado poder emitir
regulación que sea necesaria para
atender una emergencia de cualquier tipo
en este caso hablamos de la pandemia por
kobe 19 sin tener que pasar por el
congreso de la república es decir de
alguna manera se salta uno de los
poderes públicos distintos al poder
ejecutivo también le dan la capacidad de
contratar y entrar recursos públicos sin
los controles tradicionales que pueden
tener el uso de recursos en cualquier
escenario normal
y de nuevo esta situación hace parte de
la normalidad que hemos visto las
tendencias que hemos visto en muchos
países pero el momento de ponerlas en
una balanza frente a otras condiciones
vemos que esa concentración aumenta la
discrecionalidad del ejecutivo aumenta y
se pone en juego en detrimento otros
poderes públicos y en particular la
posibilidad de mantener un sistema de
control estable e independiente señor
hernández hace un momento usted nos
hablaba del problema de la
centralización con esta
concentración de poder que transparencia
por colombia está exponiendo cómo quedan
las regiones del país si todas las
decisiones están centralizadas
nuestro diseño institucional es de un
estado en país que tiene una
descentralización importante es decir
tenemos un poder y cultivo muy fuerte en
condiciones normales que se ha hecho una
fuerte en el marco de la pandemia y en
los últimos meses y los gobiernos
descentralizados en este momento han
tenido que atender una emergencia con
toda la razón lo cual le ha puesto mayor
peso y mayor necesidad de trabajo y hace
más difícil que mantenga un equilibrio
frente a las decisiones del gobierno
central en general en colombia los
gobiernos descentralizados siguen
manteniendo capacidad de contratación de
acción pero en este contexto que
nosotros estamos planteando algunas de
las tendencias que han habido durante
los últimos años se hacen aún más
evidentes un gobierno descentralizado
con menos capacidad con mayor demanda de
atención a emergencias con una
representación política en las
decisiones del gobierno central
relativamente débil
y la necesidad de atender una situación
que ha hecho que en buena medida su
planeación para los próximos cuatro años
como lo tenemos en nuestro marco legal
colombiano colombiano haya quedado atrás
tocada y de nuevo en el marco de estas
difíciles condiciones mantener un
equilibrio con el gobierno central se
vuelve bastante complejo las denuncias
que llevan a toda esta exposición que
usted hace son la elección de personas
cercanas al gobierno en cargos en
fiscalía y procuraduría que son cargos
que deberían ejercer control sobre el
ejecutivo entonces cómo afecta esto la
independencia en términos prácticos
ese es otro de los elementos sobre los
cuales estamos llamando la atención y
nuevo de nuevo nosotros venimos
analizando todas estas situaciones a lo
largo de los últimos meses y la alerta
está porque hoy en día se configuran
todos estos elementos a las cuales se
suman lo que se acaba de mencionar
la realidad que tenemos hoy en día es
que la fiscalía general de la nación la
defensoría del pueblo la procuraduría
general de la nación a partir de enero
del próximo año van a estar lideradas
por personas muy cercanas al presidente
de la república esto genera un riesgo y
un cuestionamiento en la independencia
que estas personas pueden tener frente a
decisiones investigaciones sanciones que
eventualmente tienen que tomar hacia
equipo gabinete y en general puede
activo que por supuesto está controlado
por el presidente iván duque y por lo
tanto estamos en una situación de nuevo
en que el control se debilita y la
discrecionalidad aumenta lo cual nos
genera alertas frente a riesgos de
corrupción en nuestro país muchas
gracias a ustedes por las explicaciones
y a nuestros televidentes continúen con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]